[Applaudissements]
daniel grémillet pour le groupe l'est
républicain
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le président ce ministre le
président de la république le 11 octobre
2010 est déclaré les états généraux de
l'alimentation aux deux objectifs le
premier permettre aux agriculteurs de
vivre du prix payé de permettre à tous
dans la chaîne de valeur de vivre
dignement et le second de permettre à
chacune et à chacun d'avoir accès à une
alimentation saine durable et sûre il
déclarait aussi il est plus possible
qu'aujourd'hui en france un tiers des
agriculteurs gagnent moins de 350 euros
par an et aujourd'hui où en sommes-nous
vous nous en est faite par moi parlons
vous nous et fait naître beaucoup
d'espoirs vous nous avez parlé la montée
en gamme
la seule montée en gamme qui ont vu les
agriculteurs ce sont des contraintes
supplémentaires
ce sont des charges supplémentaires ce
sont 80 intrusion dans des élevages
démontrant la maltraitance des animaux
et jamais on a vu une vidéo montrant un
agriculteur pleurer devant un animal qui
me lève de périr ce qu'on leur a fait
croire dans cette montée en gamme
c'est aussi les accords dumas corse où
les attaques hors du ceta voyez ce
ministre il y avait beaucoup d'attentes
et beaucoup d'espoirs vous l'avez vous
même déclaré cette semaine parce que
cette montée en gamme
rien n'est arrivé chez agriculteurs vous
avez dit les habitants n'ont pas eu le
fruit de cette loi les galim qu'allez
vous répondre aux agriculteurs à qui
vous avez fait naître autant d'espoir
pour nous répondre
la parole comme sioniste d'agriculture
de l'aliment